we are youth from around the country
here to school so today show them that
climate change is real it's happening
that they need to do something about it
this school Richard there
we're gonna
the question is whether is natural or
whether it's a man-made
man-made contributes to it so does not
we're just stewards of the
a generation
respect and sure
why did you but no on the Senate bill I
said some of it tonight I will encourage
you to look further into science then to
the science people can no longer keep it
alive that's very very cold out very
unseasoned oh so they have mr. president
catch this I'm pretty nervous I'm
excited to meet them Fisher mostly
because she is my senator and she is
supposed to be representing Nebraska you
know we hear from the administration and
many people on the other side that are
saying well the debates over
why would argue that the debate is not
over and as someone who is supposedly so
in touch with their constituents I'm
hoping to have a good conversation with
her especially with her our current
situation with the Keystone XL pipeline
she's severally an intense woman and I
would have really loved having a
conversation with her but obviously
that's not possible right now so I don't
agree with the notion that some are
putting out there including scientists
that somehow there are actions we can
take today that would actually have an
impact on what's happening in our
climate I'm here to meet with Senate
Rubio Jack levy
hi mrs. Decker this is Jack lady I am a
high-schooler adapt from Florida Florida
up in DC at the moment and we're trying
to meet the senator Rubio to set the
meeting with other hemorrhoid staffer
your presence here is extremely
important because politicians know that
what you are talking about your fellow
students are talking about that is
what's coming down the pike of young
people want change change will come
sooner or it will come later
but it's gonna come sick of hearing
politicians argue about whether global
warming is real well maybe it's time to
listen to America's eight